はい 体の管理と心の管理
はい まあさっさと進んでいきます
肉体を育てましょう って
まあちょっとあの変なタイトルつけたんです
で で ブッダが肉体について育ち方は教えていませんだけど
まあかなりありますよ
ものすごい では 皆様 肉体を育てましたら
結構ね 興味ありますからね
で 何をしても変えることができない基礎的なブループリントがありますね
青写真 青写真 体には一応お腹に誕生した瞬間で青写真があります
青写真で建物を作るんだけど
内装やら外観やら まあ好き勝手に変化できますよ
設備とかね 中の部屋の数とかね
青写真は変わらないんです
これは業が作るんですね
業が作ったんです しかし
それから悪行為をしたり
これ漢字間違い 善っていうのは良いなんですね
あの これがこれじゃないんですね
善 良い善行為をしたりして
体を意図的に変化させることはある程度でできます
だから皆様はいっぱい悪行為していくらで体変わりますよ
あるいは善行為をしてください
悪行為 善行為するたびに体が変わってきますけど
あの青写真の上なんです
子供の頃 病弱で体力もなかった子が
あとプロのスポーツマンになることもあり得るでしょ
子供の頃 お母さんがこいつはもう1０歳まででも生き延びるかどうか
心配は心配という すごい病弱で風邪引くわ熱は出すわ
あれやこれやとかね 肺炎になるわとか
でもなんのことなく  16
18で二十歳になってくると
いきなりもう元気になっちゃって
頑張って頑張って頑張って
まあスポーツマンになってしまうっていうのは
こんなのがあり得るんですよ
で 悪感情で妄想にふけって
悪思考を専門で生きることで
良い体で生まれても早くも壊れて退化することもあります
例えば すごくいい体で生まれても
それから悪口 悪感情で憎しみ
嫉妬だけがパワー えっとえっとえっとえっと
軌道エネルギーにして
軌道力にして生きると
見る見るうちに体壊れていくんです
醜くなっていくんです
すごい完璧な健康的な体で生まれても
もういろんなところ壊れていくんです
早くもがんになったり
いろんなことになります
退化します ああ この子ならもう 80歳までは間違いなしと小さい時に思っても
悪思考で悪感情で生きてみると
二十歳で終わってしまうということもあり得る
日夜良い明るい思考で過ごすことで
耐久性のある体に変えることもできます
もし我々は日夜明るい思考
ポジティブ思考でニコニコと笑っていると
体はすごい耐久性があるのです
それなんです  ちょっと脱線して言いますけど
あのウイルスは怖いわ
心配どうしようどうやって洗わなくちゃ
マスクじゃとかね そんなね
敵対心では体が弱くなるんです
だからまあつけてもいいんだけど
まあまあっていう感じで
まあまあニコニコと笑っていると感染しませんよ
で ウイルスに感染した人の面倒見てあげても
まあよかった 私はもう病気にかかってないんだけれど
じゃああんたの面倒見ますよとかね
で 面倒見てあげて 面白いことは感染しません
私はやったことありますよ
この伝染病とかね なんかこれ危ないと
私はかかったことがないんだからかかるだろうというね
気をつけると思って やっぱりそれでも人がもうすごい苦しんでいるところだからね
面倒見るぞと ただ 自分にはかからない
必ずするはずなんですだけど
で それから食べ物の管理なんですね
健康で美しくいるためには
ます明るい思考でいることなんです
1 善行為することなんです
なんか関係ないように見えるでしょ
健康で美しく長生きしたければ
人助けをしたり 善行為をしたりしないと
これ 1 2番目は思考 いつでも生きとし生けるものが幸せでありますようにという思考できること
みるみるうちに綺麗になっていくんです
みるみるうちにオーラが出てきて
すごいインパクトのある人間になっているのです
見事に変化しますよ 体が
しかし 日本人が一年経ってみたらアメリカ人になったってそれはないんです
アボ写真ですからね 業が作った
しかし あれびっくりという風な
このオーラがある人間には物質は変わるんです
それで明るい思考と善行為
それで終わり まあ最後にそんな大したことはないんだけど
食べ物の管理 食べ物によっても変わるでしょ
だから食べ物の管理するんです
で 環境を変えることも
でも体に良い影響も悪い影響も与えられるのです
環境を変えることでも体を変えることはできます
じゃあ皆さん その 4つ揃ってみればどうですかね
抜群にいい体になりますよ
業思考 それから 何だったっけ
栄養と  栄養と環境 こんなにまとめて健康で長生きできる方法っていうのはありますかね
ヨーガとかは 他の宗教でこんなに科学的に
まだ無理も言ってないんです
嘘も言ってないんです
アボ写真のこともはっきり言ってますからね
はい 次出てきます しかし
これは一件落着ではありません
八足そろったらはい  OK 終わりって決定決着はないんです
なんでですか 達した 合格しましたではありません
生きる体は変化しますので
体を変えるプロセスには終了ということはないんです
だから 一応健康な体になっても体変化するでしょ
だから この４条件揃うことはずっと揃ってあげなくちゃいけない
これややこしいじゃないんです
運転を考えてください
皆様方 エンジンかけてギアを入れた瞬間から
また旅を終わるところまで気をつけなくちゃいけないでしょ
そんなもんです 人生も
たいそう努力してしたからといって
老いと死も避けられません
またオチがあるんですね
では 運転する人と同じく
ずっとこの 4つの条件を保っていくと
しかし 老いてきますよ
老い老いてきましたから
勘違いしないでください
老いるんです 死ぬんです
これがオチなんです 頑張っても
それは忘れちゃうと精神的にショックを受けちゃって
あの 4つが壊れるんです
だから人間は必ず私は老いる
死ぬのだ 私は死ぬのだっていうことは前提にしておいてから
健康な体を作るために頑張るんです
そこは仏教のすごいレベルの高いやり方なんです
あれ 中国人やったように
不死不老の不死 不老不死のことを考えて毒飲んだりはしません
水銀とかね はい 次に心育てますよ
これは嫌ですね 体まで出てしまう
もう時間も時間だと思いますけど
一応体はそういうふうに育ちます
心育ててる方法 これに対しては
仏教は絶対的な専門家なんです
肉体に対していろいろ人がいるかもしれませんだけど
それも仏教には勝てっこはないんだけど
しかし 心の場合は外の世界ではいません
仏教はもう独占的な専門家なんです
しかし 臆病の心は体に隠れているので
肉体の成長に大いに興味はあるが
心の成長に対しては興味は皆無です
でしょ？正直になってください
皆様にしても 体のことなら大いに興味があります
乗ってきます これ食べたらこうなるんだよと
この瞑想すれば 1週間で 5キロ減りますよと言ったら
もうビルが爆破するぐらい来ると思いますよ
もうどこかのあの あの両国
なんとかあれ なんていうの？相撲部屋
国技館  国技館で瞑想会やる羽目になっちゃうんです
1週間で10キロぐらい痩せますよと言っちゃったら
それぐらい肉体には興味があります
しかし 心になってくるともう興味は皆無なんですね
また 他人の叱責は楽ですが
自分自身の叱責はできないんですね
他人にギャーギャー言うのは楽ですけど
自分を戒めることというのは相当難しいんですね
理解しやすい例が仏教にあります
己の解脱を 後に死刑な後のではないんですね
後にして これの間違ってます
どこでしたっけ？え？はい
そこののですね それは後にして
一切衆生を救済することに一部の仏教徒は頑張っています
これは極小の道なのに
大乗の道だと自画自賛もなさるんです
あれは酷小乗なんです
自分のことを置いといて
人に大きなお世話なんですけど
しかし 教育を受けたことがない人からね
教育を受けられるかと疑問でしょう
だから自分が悟ったこと
解脱したこともないのに
他人を救ったって言っちゃうと危ないんでしょ
私には運転できんしたことはないが
君たちをみんなを運転してあげますと
逃げてください だから私はあれは極小乗だと言ったのは
あの他宗教批判ではなくて
教理学的なポイントなんです
今日はすごく難しくなるんだからね
それちょっと置いておきます
後で説明入りますね 臆病が心
心は  臆病なじゃないですか
そうなんですね え 違いますね
臆病な心は 臆病な心がね
臆病の心は な臆病の心は独裁者なんです
このあの これダジャレじゃなくて
この あの 何て言いますか
このパラドックスパラドックスが必要なんです
これポイントなんですね
パラドックスですから
臆病と独裁っていうのはね
臆病の心が独裁者っていう
これ大事なポイントを覚えておいてください
私はもう打ち間違いばっかしですからね
人は解脱人を解脱させません
救えません だって心はあのあれでしょ
支配者でしょ 救ってあげろとはね
単純に嘘です 汝を救ってあげますとかね
あれ 単純な嘘なんです
心の法則を知らないだけ
その方法すらもないんです
一切衆生を救いましょうと
どんな方法で では 各大乗仏教の宗派のどんな方にでも聞いてみてください
禅宗でも臨済宗でも日蓮でも何でもいいんです
もうプロ中のプロに聞いてみてください
教授の中の教授に聞いてみてください
大乗仏教の一切衆生は救おうと言ってはいるんだけど
その方法はと どうやって救うのかと
全くもないんです ありえないんです
ないのはその方々悪いわけじゃなくて
ないんだからなんです
なのにそんなこと言っちゃうと
極清浄仏教になるんです
実質的に だって自分のこともやってないでしょ
清浄と言われる我々は自分のことぐらいは気をつけますからね
人のことを置いておいて
人に水をあげられるが
飲ませるとは拷問でしょ
喉が渇いたんだけどね
水一杯ちょうだいと言ったら
そのあそこさんがね 水持って口に入れてこうやってやっちゃうと
あれって丁寧と思う？私の鼻もこうやって留めて
口を強引に開けて ガタガタと中に入れるとか
そこまでやる 喉が渇いたと言ったら
水一杯はいどうぞと それで終わりでしょうに
それで丁寧でしょうに
そこまで常識でしょうに
飲ませるとは何ですかね
自力で飲めない人に飲ませるがね
病気で倒れている人はでは飲ませますよ
薬とかなんとか入れて
それは体の中に取り入れることは
それでも本人次第なんです
水でも だからつけませんよ
人は で 人に教えられるが理解させることは不可能です
学校の先生には教えることはできます
工夫して工夫して しかし理解させてあげますとかね
できません 本人が理解しなくちゃいけないんです
怒るなかれと言えるが
怒りの悪さも教えられるが
怒らないことは本人次第です
例えば私は怒らない なんとか本書いて書いたそうですけど
忘れちゃった内容まで
で 誰か私のところに 先生
私を怒らせ怒れない人間にしてくれと言ったら
私にはこの馬鹿出ていけだけですよ
お前の顔は見たくないんだよと
だってどうやって私にできるの？怒るなよ
あれって最悪よ 最低 気持ち悪い
負け犬 そこまでは言えますけど
本人 あ そうか じゃあ俺が負け犬になりたくはない
頑張る 本人次第でしょ
怒らないようにしてあげることは不可能です
欲の恐ろしさを教えられるが
欲張らないようにしてあげるとは成り立ちません
あの一神教もあなたは神を信じますか？でストップでしょ
ストップしなくてはならないでしょ
だから新宿でね ずっともう何十万人にも人に聞こえますけどね
あなたは神を信じますか？神の最後の審判はそろそろ出ますよとか
神はすべての悪人を裁きて裁いて良い世界は作るぞとかずっと言ってますけどね
罪を悔い改めましょうとかね
だからあなたは神を信じますか？と聞いたら
いえ 信じませんって言ったら
それで終わり 信じなさい
信じさせますとかね これできないんです
だからこういう信仰型の宗教にしても
救済 救済と言ってるイエスが我は光であり
我は救済者でありとかね
言ってないんだそうですよ
あれはジョンという本に書いてますけど
あの人はもうもう二百二百年ぐらい後でいい加減に書いた本なんです
あの もともとの四つのテキストとはまるっきり違うことを書いています
だから作品です そちらではね
すごいイエスがえらいことをやっちゃいます
パンをたくさんの人々に配ったりとかね
古い福音書ではないんです
そういう軌跡とかも  ヨハネ
ヨハネ ヨハネ  ヨハネでしたっけ
ジョンと英語で言いますけどね
ヨハネですかね うん だからそういうふうに自慢げに言うんだけど
やっぱり救いは人間の個人的なものなんです
これもうどうにもならんですね
心の侵害 心は独立自立
独裁です 独立国家にアドバイスはできます
命令は成り立ちません
侵害です 違反です だから
国の何て言いますか ソブリニティ
独立でしたっけね それぞれの国が自分で独立というかね
自分の自由があるでしょうね
主権ですね  主権 で だからこれまずいんだよと言えるます
言えますよ ヒラリークリントンが来てね
これなんとかならないのか
ちょっとまずいだよと
それであんたに命令します
これやめなさいと これできませんよ
やっちゃうと これ違反なんです
だからアメリカ失敗なんでしょ
韓国に命令 令状を送るんですね
原子爆弾作るのやめなさい
何者ですかね ではなくて
これ困りますよと お願いしますよと
イランに対してやめなかったら爆弾を落としてやるぞと
で イランもアメリカからかって法律を犯っていること知ってるんだからね
いろいろ言うんですね
主権にはね 我々の主権がありますからね
そういうことを聞く必要はないんだよと
だからからかってるんですね
作りたければすぐ作りますよと
本当はイランには作る目的ないんです
だからアメリカがいじっていじって作らせていただいているだけです
もしかすると 情報を調べたらもっとその考えがないんで
あの連中は自分の宗教のことで精一杯だから
お互い喧嘩することには忙しいんです
イランでは こんな原子爆弾なんか作ったってどうする？イスラエルと戦うこんな余裕
暇がないんです お互い殺し合いしなくちゃいかんでしょうに
で 人は他人の心を支配したいと思っている
なのに 人間どもっていうのは人を支配したいんですね
なんで人を支配したいんですかね？あれ
自分の心の問題なんです
心は独裁者だから 他人の心も支配したいと思っちゃうんです
成り立ちませんよ 他人の心も独裁者だから
一人一人が別々な主権を持ってる国なんです
だから独裁できませんよ
これ みんな失敗するんです
できるのは洗脳すること
マインドコントロールすることです
だからやられています
みんな 要するに 心は心を壊すことです
だから宗教は必ず皆様の健康な心を壊すんです
壊してマインドコントロールして洗脳するんです
政治家もマインドコントロールするんです
それでアメリカも世界の各国各国をマインドコントロールして洗脳しようとしているんです
力はそうやって広げようとしているんです
しかし 一人一人の人間が独立国家であって
誰の命令も聞く必要はないんです
アドバイスは聞くのは礼儀ですけどもね
他人は自分の幸せを願うならば
他人のアドバイスを聞くことです
が 命令は聞く必要はないのです
したがって ブッダは教えるんです
それだけ 偉大なる絶対的な教師
師匠です ブッダは偉大なる師匠
間違いなく理解できるように
皆自力で合格できるように教えるんです
心の独立を侵害しないんです
仏教は 心を育てる方法を詳細に説明するんです
これだ これだ これだ これでこれでこれと全部説明するんです